overall do you feel like Janelle's okay
no I don't feel Janelle's okay I'm just
so so so worried about Jenelle Jenelle
Evans mom says she's scared for her
daughter's safety and her own scans me
on part one of the Teen Mom 2 reunion
Barbara Evans expressed her concerns
over her daughter's husband David Eason
blaming him for Jenelle's absence at the
reunion she's on here really because you
know David couldn't come Oh God as you
know he has to be everywhere with her
because he wouldn't let her come if he
wasn't coming I think so earlier this
year
MTV fired Eason from the show after he
was accused of making a series of
homophobic comments online barb has
primary custody of Janelle's son from a
previous relationship Jace he was
recently in the car with Janelle when
she was involved in a road rage incident
that ended with her allegedly pulling a
gun out on another driver it's very just
a sergeant I don't know I just disguise
this guy it's just so I can't even
describe and barb didn't stop there well
yells at me you know he's always has
guns he's teaching these kids to shoot
guns when they're like two years old
three years old what the heck is that
I just have this feeling when you get a
call one of these days that's not gonna
be a pretty one
you